[Music]  the fate of the universe lies on your  shoulders now whatever you do don't push  this but because that will set off the  bomb immediately and we'll all be dead  now repeat back what I just said oh no  that's the button that will kill  everyone try again uncle mm-hmm uh-huh  Oh No  Showtime a-holes  [Music]  [Music]  screw you sir  [Music]  does anybody have any paper out there I  want to put some tape over the death but  nobody has any tape not a single person  has tape you have an atomic bomb in your  bag if anybody's gonna that's a really  bad sign  you're a touch someone I can feel their  feelings your feel yeah yeah I guess  yeah I feel a general unselfish love for  just matter no no no I don't know  see you stole everyone your deepest  darkest secret dude come on I think  you're overreacting a little  you must be so embarrassed yes I am a  dancer Cory's not you just need to find  a woman who is pathetic like you thanks  boy  do you need a hug